hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outboard and this is it
the final battle in blackover is now
underway and a character that we know
and love just demonstrated wizard King
levels of power did Tabata just reveal
the next wizard King and then he also
just break the hearts of every osta
Fanboy myself included is a major plot
twist About to Rock Black Clover let's
get into it you guys know how this works
if you enjoy my Black Clover content and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now it
only takes you a second but it helps me
out with the YouTube algorithm and if
you are one of the over 50 of people who
watch my videos regularly but you still
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing on YouTube is
completely free but it means a lot for
the channel finally this video will of
course contain Black Clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned
in the previous chapter the final battle
for the Clover Kingdom capital finally
began as Lucius and his paladins
descended upon the city and some of the
strongest Mages in the Kingdom rose up
to defend the capital including Yami
Meadow Leona fuegoleon William Charlotte
and many others one of those others is
of course our boy yuno the star of this
chapter but more on that later as the
final battle got underway multiple
powerful characters who already died
many years ago were brought back by
Lucius as his paladins including knocked
brother Morgan and Noel's mother asier
Silva Morris is also there although he
wasn't dead he was just severely injured
and then Lucius healed him and at the
end of the previous chapter an entire
Army of angelic creatures started
descending on the capitol the latest
chapter begins as the magic Knight
captains scrambled to deal with the
sudden appearance of Morgan and asier
and with the Jack's severe injury that
Morgan inflicted upon Him using light
magic before Jack even had a chance to
realize what was happening William
immediately initiates his world tree
magic and rushes at Lucius he seems to
have activated his healing Magic on Jack
and at the same time he proclaims that
he is who he is today because of Julius
and so he vows to stop Lucius even if it
costs him his life but before William or
his magic can reach the villain Lucius
creates one of those time magic spheres
that Julius was so known for and this
stops William in his tracks in fact it
looks like William's right arm and part
of his right leg are literally falling
apart because they got stuck inside the
time sphere I think that Lucius might
have sped up the Aging of William's arm
inside the sphere and that is why it
looks like it's coming apart but we
don't get to see the exact extent of
William's injuries because the chapter
moves very quickly as a concern
Charlotte screams out William's name
Lucius confidently states that none of
them are his real enemy because none of
them have the power to stop him Lucius
calls on the final judgment to commence
and those Angelic looking beings who are
flying over the capitol begin to shoot
magic beams down towards the city the
immense amount of magic that is about to
rain down on the capital is overwhelming
for the Mages below to even comprehend
and a bunch of them just conclude that
all hope is lost this massive attack
from the air is about to kill them all
and there is no realistic way to stop it
Lucius speaks the word perish and then
thousands of beams of light Begin to
Fall upon the capital and most citizens
below just look on in shock and
amazement this looks like the end for
all of them or is it well of course it
isn't it's Black Clover but how do they
survive this attack you know and his
star magic come to the rescue he
arranges multiple stars in a circular
formation over the entire capital and
these Stars Then begin to generate a
mass magical portal this portal simply
consumes all the thousands of light
beams and teleports them somewhere else
saving the capital and leaving everyone
there in an even greater State of Shock
and amazement now of course we knew that
you know star magic had teleportation
power and in the past we've seen him
teleport from one of his stars to
another but this is a new type of attack
that uses multiple stars to create an
absolutely massive Capital city-sized
portal Yami can't believe how far yuno
has progressed with star magic in just
over a year and Yami is reminded of the
day that Julius used his time magic to
save the entire Capital City from
patrie's Massive Attack upon witnessing
yuno's ability William sees that yuno is
already far stronger than him and Lucius
immediately acknowledges yuno as the
captain of the Golden Dawn thinking of
all the people that Lucius has hurt
including of course Asta sister Lily and
the other orphans and father or Sia
after they saw what happened to Austin
Lilly a fierce you know declares that he
will never forgive Lucius sogradis for
what he has done but the reason that
yuno says that he will defeat Lucius
right here now is not because he can't
forgive him but because he is the man
who will become the wizard King Lucia
smiles and says that he will have to
destroy you know right now and there's a
whole bunch of stars begin to appear
around you know this chapter comes to an
end and man shiz just got real let's be
honest yuno is way stronger than he was
before and he has unlocked the kind of
power that would have been considered
strictly wizard King level at the
beginning of the story even Yami makes
the comparison between Julius saving the
capital from pottery and you know saving
the capital from Lucius and the
implication is clear yuno's power is now
comparable to the power of Julius at the
beginning of the story yuno is now far
stronger than William who began the
story as the captain of the Golden Dawn
and so yuno can now be said to be well
beyond the level of a captain he may
have already reached the level of wizard
King it's clear that Lucius sees yuno as
a serious threat and as a result he has
decided that he must destroy yuno
immediately but will he succeed or will
you no somehow resist the force of
lucius's godly power are we about to see
an epic Clash between Lucius and his
paladins and yuno and the magic Knight
captains and then just as you know is
about to lose Austin returns in the nick
of time to back yuno up that would be a
pretty amazing way for Tabata to bring
Asta back to the Clover Kingdom and that
would also be an amazing reunion between
yuno and Asta there's also a possibility
that yuno could be killed or seriously
injured before Asta returns this means
that when he returns Asta will be
absolutely Furious and he will be even
stronger than ever before because he
will be seeking revenge against Lucius I
mean anything is possible this is the
final battle but knowing Tabata my money
is definitely not on you know or any
major character dying knowing what we
know about character deaths in this
series I just don't feel that kind of
tension even though this is the final
battle what do you guys think Am I Wrong
to just assume that no major character
will die based on what we've seen so far
in the series or do you agree with my
take what will happen in the final fight
between yuno and Lucius will yuno
actually hold his own or will also have
to show up to back him up another thing
that I want to talk about is the fact
that in this chapter Tabata seems to be
heavily implying that you know is Wizard
King material could this actually mean
that yuno will become the next wizard
King and not Asta obviously this is also
yuno's dream it's not just Austin's
dream but I think that most of us want
Asta to achieve his dream more than we
want yuno to achieve it however the
story might have bigger plans for Asta
so yuno becoming wizard King may
actually make more sense
depending on how strong Austin's
anti-magic becomes by the end of the
series he may become the protector of
the entire continent or maybe even the
entire world while you know range as the
wizard King of the Clover Kingdom or
maybe hasta will become the new ruler of
the underworld after all the cliff off
devils are defeated and after asta's
secret connection to asteroth is
revealed what secret connection you
might ask well if you've seen my
previous Black Clover videos then you
know that I believe that there is a good
reason why astroth is the only one of
the strongest Devils that still hasn't
been officially introduced in the story
there's a theory that asteroth is
Austin's dad there's also a theory that
Julius used lucius's Soul magic to split
the soul of aeroth into two and Austin
liebe are the two halves of asteroth's
Soul Asta and Roth but whatever the
truth is it is possible that when we
learn more about astroth we will see
that asta's Destiny is bigger than just
becoming wizard King that said we could
still have Asta becoming the wizard king
and you know becoming the king of the
Spade Kingdom so you never know what do
you guys think will happen who will be
the next wizard King will it be you know
will it be osta will it be someone else
entirely like Yami or Mero Leona or
maybe Julius will just banish Lucius
from his body and then be like no I'm
keeping the job you youngsters can wait
give me your choice for the next wizard
King down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this Black Clover video
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like right now and if you
are one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos but still haven't taken
the time to subscribe do me a big favor
and subscribe right now don't forget to
also hit the notification Bell to turn
on all notifications subscribing is
completely free it's only a click away
and it helps me out a lot with the
channel you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys